in our everyday life most things are
generally normal and routine a bird a
tree a city block a drive home from work
a meal a load of laundry a night of
sleep and so on after a certain age of
adolescence most things begin to fall
into this category of averageness or
tediousness this can for obvious reasons
post problems on our experience of life
a frequent sense of boredom and monotony
science religions and philosophies often
work to provide us with answers and
clarity about the universe and our
existence within it we seek to learn
about what we as a collective species
know about ourselves and this reality in
order to aid our experience of it this
can be helpful of course but perhaps an
equally valuable and often neglected
source of wisdom joy and vitality can be
found not in what we know but in what we
don't know a deep contemplation and
assimilation of the unknown into our
daily life 19th century writer Henry
David Thoreau writes my desire for
knowledge is intermittent but my desire
to commune with the spirit of the
universe to be intoxicated with the
fumes call it of that divine nectar to
bear my head through atmospheres and
over Heights unknown to my feet is
perennial and constant which is to say
the experience and effects of concrete
knowledge can be fleeting but the wonder
found in the spirit of the unknown can
be constant and enduring with no more
than a glance upward at a clear starry
night sky as we stare into the eyes of
the incomprehensible and infinite space
above us we are likely to experience an
overwhelming awareness of how little we
know and how little we are the universe
stares back at us with its stark glare
and reminds us how deeply strange and
unclear our life really is even in the
most simple and normal the great
cosmologists Carl Sagan said the cosmos
is all that is or was or ever will be
our feeblest contemplations of the
cosmos stir us there's a tingling in the
spine a catch in the voice a faint
sensation as if a distant memory of
falling from a height this feeling of
awe is immensely liberating and
provoking it reminds us that we stand at
the
crossroads of the infinite in the finite
the everything and the nothing the
knowing and the unknowing in truth no
matter what we think we know we are
probably wrong and no matter what anyone
else thinks they know they are probably
wrong nobody ever figures out what life
is all about and it doesn't matter
explore the world nearly everything is
really interesting if you go into it
deeply enough said renowned theoretical
physicist Richard Feynman at this point
no one truly knows what's going on in
any fundamental sense nothing about this
life is simple or clear and nothing down
here on earth including us from the
perspective of the stars matters all
that much to anything beyond itself
paradoxically in this we find great
opportunity for wisdom humility
exploration and profound experience in
even the most common in mundane there is
complexity and strangeness we don't even
know why we sleep or dream we don't know
how most of our brain works or what
consciousness is we don't know if time
is real in any physical sense we don't
know what gravity is or why it is we
don't know if there are infinite other
universes or dimensions around us right
now we don't know why energy or matter
even came to be in the first place or
why it was followed by a perfect
sequence of colliding combining
exploding and emerging all to put us
here right now able to ask why at the
base of almost everything the resulting
statement is we don't know when we
disregard this unknowingness we can
easily become disinterested uninspired
and worn out of this life we can put
great stress on things that perhaps
don't matter all that much and neglect
our experiences and things that do we
can feel the pressure and anxiety of
chasing perfection and certainty which
of course at this moment do not exist
alternatively the frequent consideration
and acceptance of the unknown within
every moment and in everything can bring
us back down to our earthly innocence
and curiosity and open us up to an
appreciation for all things people and
ideas we should look to the universe
often not solely for answers but for a
perspective for a healthful adjustment
and aerial consideration of our daily
life arguably within this practice the
little things in life become more
exciting and striking
the mistakes in the annoyance has become
less significant the calm becomes easier
and everyday activities of our life that
we so often view as wasteful and tedious
reveal to be wonderfully strange in
curious parts of our existence that we
should perhaps make efforts to ponder
and appreciate as often as we can as if
to say I'd love to marvel at and enjoy
this work of art I've created the
universe gave itself humanity through
our eyes the universe is perceiving
itself through our ears of the universe
is listening to its harmonies we are the
witnesses through which the universe
becomes conscious of its glory of its
magnificence said 20th century American
British philosopher Allen Watts and what
a shame it would be to waste this
experience by denying said glory and
magnificence in a clear starry night sky
we see beauty not because we know where
all the stars came from or where they
will all go but because we don't in the
scope of the bigger picture the only
thing that seems to remain sizeable and
relevant about us is that we are here
able to look up to the stars any night
we'd like during our brief and fleeting
exploration of this life and wonder why
they are there we must remember that the
unknown is always above below and beside
us whenever we needed
you